Have you ever looked longingly into your cat’s
eyes and wondered, “why are you pupils terrifying
little slits, you nighttime killer of beasts?!”
I have.
Hello everyone, it’s Amy with you on DNews,
and you’re watching me right now because
the light from your screen is passing through
your cornea, being bent in just the right
way that it passes through your circular pupil
into your eye hitting your retina so your
brain can receive the image and, well, you
can see!
In all that, the pupil plays the key role
as the adjustable opening that controls the
intensity of light allowed to enter your eye,
just like the aperture on a camera.
In humans, our pupils dilate to allow more
light in and contract to allow less light
in.
But not all eyes in the animal kingdom are
created equal, nor are all pupils.
When we think about different eyes, we have
to remember that eyes didn’t develop on
land.
Nothing did.
The first eyes of the first living things
were under water where light moves different
and moisture is built into the environment.
As different species developed in and out
of water, pupil shapes have gotten weird.
Or at least, weird when we’re used to looking
at our own circular pupils.
Obviously they’re totally normal and natural.
The one most of us are familiar with is the
vertical slit pupil, which, interestingly,
has developed in a variety of species independently
including canines, felines, some snakes, geckos,
crocodiles, and some birds.
That’s a pretty wide variety of animals,
but what they all have in common is that they
are nocturnal predators who don’t stand
too high off the ground.
One benefit is that slit pupils can contract
and dilate more than circular ones.
Think of a cat who is awake and running around
in full daylight and in the middle of the
night.
Cats can see far better than we can in those
two extreme light environments.
Some more recent research suggests that slit
pupils also help predatory animals see color
in different light conditions, leaving a larger
amount of the retina open to receive wavelengths
of light that translate to different colours.
A vertical pupil also affects the depth of
the image that the eye can see as well as
an increased horizontal movement in sharp
focus, something predators like cats need
more than humans.
Vertical pupils are also less noticeable than
round ones when a predator is staring you
down.
But there’s another pupil shape that also
developed independently among a number of
species and that’s the horizontal slit.
Even-toed ungulates as well as all equines,
mongooses, some frogs and toads, and octopi
have horizontal pupils.
That’s a pretty interesting mix that might
not seem to have a lot of obvious commonalities
to explain their shared pupil shape, but they
are all predators with eyes on the side of
their heads, and with a lateral pupil, they
all get an extremely wide field of view, sometimes
nearing a full 360 degrees.
So those, vertical and horizontal slits, are
the major ones.
There are some even stranger pupils out there,
particularly lurking in the water or in species
that have to see both underwater and in the
air.
Some species of gecko have pinhole pupils,
pupils that, when fully contracted, become
just four tiny dots vertically in the eye
that can help gauge distance.
Dolphins have pupils that look like the letter
U when fully contracted.
The cuttlefish has a super neat looking W-shaped
pupil that is actually a break in the retina.
They can look forwards and backwards at the
same time and see in polarized light, cutting
out the glare that can make it impossible
for humans to see!
In the scheme of eye-things, our eyes are
sort of the most basic, and they serve us
well!
But there’s an intense variety of pupils
out there that speaks to the amazing variety
of species on our planet.
I dig the cuttlefish pupil and find the horizontal
one a little terrifying… what’s your favourite
pupil?